well over the next half hour we'll be
discussing the latest findings plus
answering questions that you've sent in
to us here at Sky News with a panel of
experts for you and tonight I'm joined
by Professor Andrew Waterson a public
health expert at the University of
Sterling Dr Maggie wermuth a GP and
member of The Joint Committee for
vaccines and immunization and Oxana
Pidgeot the lead of outbreak educational
program in infectious diseases from the
University College London
but first our health correspondent
Ashish Joshi reports on the Omicron
variant and the latest restrictions
a fortnight before Christmas and now
this strongest of warnings about the new
covid variants we may be starting to
experience a potential tsunami of
infections we expect it to overtake
Delta within days not weeks all
household contacts of any confirmed
covert case should isolate for 10 days
regardless of their vaccination status
and even if they initially get a
negative PCR test cases of the Omicron
variant are doubling every two to three
days across the UK
here in Scotland Nicholas sturgeon wants
to cancel work celebrations I'm
concerned about the NHS about the
doctors and the nurses and the a e units
they just can't cope we've had two years
of hardship and I think it's good for
people to get together with their
families
so will the new measures be enough to
slow The Surge or will more urgent
interventions be needed the changes
today are actually relatively modest or
maybe more in future around mandatory
self-isolation for all those who've come
into contact with with a positive case
irrespective of the variant and then
also some strong advice on avoiding
mixing if possible including over the
Christmas period which is really tough
for people to hear
England's Plan B measures came into
force today with face masks now
compulsory in most public indoor venues
and people encouraged to work from home
if they can it's hoped these have been
introduced early enough to prevent
further interventions
something like 30 of the new covert
cases in London are homicron cases so we
keep everything under review but the
plan B approach that we've outlined we
believe is an appropriate and
proportionate response at the moment
omicron's arrival has threatened to
disrupt Christmas we had been waiting to
learn more about this variant and now we
know how quickly it can spread last year
all four nations announced a combined
plan to try and protect Christmas but
just a week before Christmas Day itself
those plans were scrapped new
restrictions were brought in and
Christmas was effectively canceled
once again there is little to cheer
about so far this Christmas it certainly
feels like we've been here before but
this time much more of the country is
vaccinated and that could be crucial in
deciding a very different outcome
Ashish Joshi Sky News
well let's get straight into your
questions sir and put them to our
experts tonight they are let's remind
you Professor Andrew Waterson he's a
public health expert from the public
health and population health research
group that's at the University of
Sterling Dr Maggie Weymouth is AGP and
member of the joints committee for
vaccines and immunization and Oxana
Pidgeot a lead of outbreak educational
program in infectious diseases at the
University College London good evening
to you all thanks so much for joining us
we've had so many questions in today
we've tried to narrow them down to put
them to you so we get a good mix of
questions for everyone I'll start with
this one who is responsible for
investigating the Omicron variants and
when will more data be available let's
go first to Professor Andrew Waterson
for that
um hello there
um there's a range of bodies that are
responsible if we're looking across the
UK there are different Public Health
agencies that do this
um Public Health Scotland Public Health
Wales and similar ones in England we
also have a lot of researchers in
universities and within the vaccine
manufacturing companies looking at this
but what we've really learned in the
last few months is the importance of
work going on outside the UK
um so we're drawing on the work done in
South Africa by physicians and
scientists and we're also drawing on the
work from other parts of the world that
will inform the decisions and we're
getting data all the time obviously it's
very early days the picture is becoming
clearer but it is far from clear so we
need to draw on our own internal
assessments and modeling but also use
the data that's been collected in real
world situations and in labs
a doggy Dr Maggie weirmuth let me ask
you the same when do you think more data
will be available for you to make your
assessments on the jcvi
well we've got the initial
um feedback from UK HSA who published
information on the government website
only this afternoon
um so we know that there are initial
printouts about vaccine efficacy but
these are still very small numbers uh
they're very early they are encouraging
in that we know the boosters work
they're slightly less effective but
there is a very strong message that only
having two vaccines is not good enough
and that a booster is really needed to
offer the protection that we need to get
us through this very very difficult
winter that we're anticipating
um so UK HSA are giving us the lead but
clearly we are taking the information
from around the world because they are
further into this than we are and
therefore we need to know everything we
can about this disease and how the
variants changes the severity of the
disease due to Omicron yeah it seems to
be a steep learning curve but Oksana
pisg I'm going to bring you in now for
the next question which is when is a
person who's been infected with Omicron
at their most infectious to others
well we do see that it appears that the
incubation period could be shorter with
the Omicron variant and in general we
know that the first two days before
um symptoms even present so that's what
the previous variants as well uh you
have the highest amount of um
potentially infectious and in that
entire first week as well you have the
highest amount of viral shedding so
that's why getting tested as quickly as
possible as well as doing regular
lateral flow tests before meeting with
others Etc is so critical
great thank you for that um Professor
Andrew Waterson another question for you
are we able to see how many people have
been hospitalized or even died
specifically from the Omicron variant
okay that that's a difficult question
and as with all of the answers I think
we'll be saying it's early days
um we've got the omnicron variant uh in
something like 38 countries at the
moment
um but certainly a week or so ago there
were no deaths that had been reported
according to the World Health
Organization we have had some figures
from South Africa about the treatment
there of the variant and we know that
nine of the 42 unvaccinated patients
from Omicron were being treated for the
virus and we're in need of oxygen but
that the remaining 33 although they
tested positive were actually
asymptomatic and were being treated for
other conditions so we must also
remember we've got the Delta variants as
well people will have a range of health
conditions and it will be difficult
sometimes to get accurate data as well
from some places but shouldn't just
focus on hospitalized and dying we need
to consider for instance long covid
issues and the serious impact on the NHS
um even if only a very small number of
people from a very large exposed
population who may get mild symptoms
become ill so that's why prevention is
the key really at this stage
yeah absolutely well a reminder for our
viewers the UK has recorded
448 new Omicron cases in the latest
24-hour period well that takes the total
across the country you can see that on
the graph going up there to 1
265
so far let's move on then to another
question
um this coming into us uh I'll put this
to you Dr Maggie Weymouth this person
says I caught covid in December 2020 I
then received two vaccines should I get
a booster jab or am I already protected
with natural and vaccine immunity I
guess a lot of people are are wondering
about this too
well the show's answer is yes definitely
get a booster the longer answer is your
body makes
um antibodies in response to the actual
infection that's natural immunity it
makes the same antibodies in relation to
vaccines but we know that these
antibodies uh Wane that's why we're
offering the booster program
so that it doesn't matter whether you
you have natural immunity or
vaccine-induced immunity it is not going
to stay level it is going to wane and
therefore if you've had covid over a
year ago and you've had two vaccines
then the chances are that you will have
waning immunity now depending on when
you actually had your last last dose of
vaccine so that if you've been called
for a booster have it don't feel that
you're head of the game have it if
you're eligible don't wait
um I'm going to stay with that question
for a moment because uh Professor
Waterson I I know that you feel that uh
the vaccination should also be extended
to younger children you've said between
the ages of 12 and 15 and you shouldn't
have to wait for the UK government to
advise Scotland you felt very strongly
about that didn't you
think there are different uh approaches
and different approaches in different
countries so jcvi's analyzing and
assessing the information and I think
it's indicated that it adopted a
precautionary policy but I reckon
recommending the the booster after six
months in fact in Scotland we're not
required to follow jcbi
um as Westminster is and other countries
have in fact at an earlier stage
recommended vaccinating younger people
and they've also recommended vaccinating
some groups of workers not solely on the
basis of age so we get excellent
information from jcbi but other
countries May interpret that information
differently and with Omicron now perhaps
there's an argument for being even more
precautionary than we were before
uh and if you can stay with me for the
next question um someone has written
into US say two years into the pandemic
what has the government done to prepare
for any new waves they may be expecting
from covid variants
do you want me to answer that
right okay so we've got four governments
in the UK
um a lot is Guided by what comes out
from Westminster
um the big agencies there but not all
and I think we've seen different
preparations running through the
pandemic and I think that these now
um are coming into play in terms of the
new wave so we've already heard about
changes in England that in fact are
already in place uh in Scotland and some
of them may be in place in Wales and
Northern Ireland but I think the key
thing is about taking an effective
action on things like ventilation which
means rather more than saying just open
the windows it means about Mass
compliance and there's big differences I
think between the countries there it
means working from home in a way that
people can work from home and won't be
penalized economically so we've seen
England come into line time with with
Scotland there it's certainly about
vaccines that Dr Wilma has stressed
absolutely crucial although there may be
some discussion about how exactly that's
rolled out it also means bumping up
tests and Trace and possibly looking at
vaccine passports so it's this area of
strengthening compliance that's needed
across all four countries but I think
they're all in a slightly different
position and with somewhat different
policies
I'm going to bring you in I mean do you
think we are prepared for any new wave I
mean we've already heard of course that
Omicron May well take over from the
Delta variant but how prepared are we
potentially for the next wave
foreign
well certainly there are many lessons uh
learned in the previous experience with
Delta even uh Omicron I'm sure will hot
present uh its own unique challenges but
um one of the tools that will become
available to us as well in addition to
vaccines is of course also antivirals
like multipurivir uh both Pfizer and
Merck have
um shown that this is also helpful in
reducing hospitalizations but it is
difficult in terms of ensuring that
people actually take that medication
quickly enough before symptoms develop
and a supply problem is going to be the
main challenge in the coming weeks so in
terms of uh rolling out plan b or plan C
I would say or the UK government will
have to act very quickly to try
um and cope with the the rate of
doubling that we're seeing with Omicron
and that the previous measures in this
case even though we do have vaccines uh
we may need to look at tightening things
up sooner rather than later so I think
the argument that uh wait and see has
been proven to be uh the one that has
the highest amount of costly expenses
down the road
I I guess the real question is though
that people want answered is how long
can we stay in this Perpetual state of
restrictions a new variant more
restrictions a new variant Oxana
well of course we also know that uh
we're in this position partly because we
haven't made a big enough commitment
towards vaccine equity and many high
income countries including the UK have
been hoarding vaccines and that promotes
the growth of new variants so until we
take that problem seriously uh this
could be extended towards some time I
mean there is uh people who are hoping
that this will mean there we have milder
symptoms uh but that is yet to be seen
I'm certainly the vaccines will mute the
severity of the symptoms but uh we don't
have evidence of that in unvaccinated
individuals uh particularly as the South
African population is younger so I think
that just because we want it to be over
and we're tired of all these
restrictions
um doesn't make the threat go away and
if anything we have a larger threat at
hand with Omicron
okay we're going to try and squeeze a
quick question in before we take a break
um Dr Maggie Weymouth I would like you
to answer this so someone's written in
to say my dad is due to go into hospital
to have a sister mood from inside his
chest he's had three Jabs but I'm
worried because my mum was admitted to
hospital this time last year and she
caught covid and passed away sadly are
these vaccines a match for omicrons
seeing as they were produced before this
variant was found and is it worth
waiting before he agrees to have his
procedure done we've got about a minute
for that answer
well first of all I'm very sorry to hear
about your mom's death
um and it must be very difficult trying
to make these decisions we know that
um we are in a very different place than
we were last year your mom probably
didn't have the chance of a vaccine even
one dose last December so we have
effective vaccines we have a much better
idea how to detect and treat
um covid if it comes along and but there
is always a difficult decision to make
when it's it's elective surgery it is
not someone who's ill someone's having
to make an active decision and all I can
say is have a word with a clinical team
about how urgent is this and there are
risks to delaying surgery if you're
worried about going into Hospital ring
up have a word with your consultant and
if not have a word with your GP about
the different risks and how they might
might affect you
but three vaccines means you're recently
boosted and therefore you are probably
at the most protected
um level of immunity you can possibly
have at the moment yeah which is why of
course everyone is encouraging everyone
to get their booster jobs and at least
be vaccinated if you haven't got vaccine
yet well thanks very much indeed for now
stay with us because after the break
we'll have more of your questions
including on what testing you should be
doing to protect you and your family
join us after the break
[Music]
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Sky's Chief
correspondent well there's a real sense
now that people are beginning to expect
that this whole airlift is coming to an
end and they're really really desperate
we saw snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
water yes
we help you understand the world with us
for the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change thank you
whipping crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world they were convinced the
United States would become hooked they
were right
normal Sixth Station has just come down
just landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so so hot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to this special edition of
Sky News tonight when we put your
questions to The Experts I'm joined by
Professor Andrew Watson he's a public
health expert at the University of
Sterling Dr Maggie Weymouth is a GP and
member of the joints committee for
vaccines and immunization and Oksana
pijik from the University College London
thanks very much indeed it's been great
to have your answers for our viewers
questions so far we've got a couple more
to go
one of our viewers has written in to say
would one of your experts consider
explaining about not doing a lateral
flow test at home if you have a cough or
covid symptoms this person says I was
very surprised to hear today that a
lateral flow test done at home only if
you do not have symptoms and is not
accurate if you do
um Oksana pisg I'm going to ask you that
well absolutely we know that PCR tests
are much more sensitive and specific so
uh absolutely if you do have uh cough
cold or or any of the coveted symptoms
then uh it would be a good idea to try
and get a PCR test as soon as possible
however that's not to say that if you
already have a at-home test kit you may
get a faster result and if that comes
out positive
um then you know you have an answer
that's faster I think the key Point here
is that you can't trust a a negative
lateral flow test and you would have to
really wait to get the results from the
PCR for accuracy so if it is uh if it
does come out positive it's very
unlikely that that positive is a false
positive but we cannot trust the false
negatives from the lateral flow test and
that needs to be confirmed with a PCR
test which is much more accurate yeah Dr
Maggie Weymouth you're nodding away
um as a GP I guess you will have had to
answer this question a few times
oh every time I'm a triage GP I'm
talking to people in exactly this
situation and as soon as they're ringing
up telling me that they have coughed
cold chest symptoms I'm telling them
that they can't come to our surgery
until they've organized a PCR and they
say but I've got a negative lateral flow
test
um so that is exactly the right answer
is that if you're well and you've tested
yourself and you are negative then you
are unlikely to be infectious to other
people because it is the people who are
the asymptomatic people who might spread
the infection that they're not aware of
that the lateral flows are most well
designed for as soon as you become
symptomatic you have to have a PCR
brilliant thank you
um okay one last question which is
really interesting if it turns out that
it's a much milder infection does that
mean it's dying out like the Spanish Flu
I guess that's the last pandemic we've
got everything to compare with so
Professor Andrew Waterson
um will this start dying out like the
Spanish Flu
well that's a big question I mean one of
the descriptions of Omicron has been the
greatest hits collection of mutations
um so just in terms of this particular
variant there are lots of lots of
questions it may well be milder but as
we've heard from Oksana if we're not
looking at what's going on elsewhere in
the world we may deal with our
particular mild problems but they're
going to be coming around from other
places and getting us so it does look as
if it's mild it does look as if it may
be more responsive but a mild condition
a mild variant can actually wreak havoc
with the NHS we can get loads of cases
most people not badly affected a small
number seriously affected and that can
tip the NHS over as indeed we're
concerned about flu
epidemics and so on at various times of
the year so we don't know the answer to
that yet
um and we'd be very unwired used to be
casual about how we respond prevention
is the key just very quickly going to
bring you in while we have a few more
moments left on the same question do you
think that eventually we'll find some
parallels with the Spanish Flu dying out
well I think what will make it die out
is a vaccination and making sure that we
have uh booster shots here as well as so
both and I'm getting vaccine doses first
and second everywhere else as well so in
terms of the dying out uh I don't think
that work the fastest way out is to not
wait for a natural evolution of the
virus to uh maybe weaken it the way out
is by vaccination and we have to be
creative about how we are able to also
boost Supply to get enough for third
doses here as well as everywhere else
and so that's what the World Health
Organization is currently negotiating
with the World Trade Organization to
explore we're going to have to leave it
there but I hear you on vaccine Equity
of course thanks very much indeed to all
of you thanks very much to all our
panelists and thank you to all our
viewers for all your questions tonight